[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 20 avril
21 ans après les yvelines accueilleront
l'été prochain les championnats de
france de cyclisme sur route le parcours
a été dévoilé jeudi à mantes la jolie à
parcours qui passera notamment devant
l'église notre-dame huit titres seront
en jeu durant quatre jours pma gpa don
de gamètes intelligence artificielle ou
encore saint de vie les débats sont
nombreux en ce moment autour des
questions de bioéthique
alors que s'achève la fin à la fin du
mois les états généraux débuté en
janvier qu'en pensent les associations
familiales catholiques nous poserons la
question à l'un de ses membres yvelinois
joseph mines et dans le reste de
l'actualité nous reviendrons sur la
rénovation urbaine qui rentre dans une
nouvelle phase pour certaines villes de
l'agglomération ou encore les yvelinois
qui ont largement profité du retour du
soleil et de la chaleur
cette semaine du 28 juin au 1er juillet
prochain se tiendront les championnats
de france de cyclisme sur route et cette
année ce sont les yvelines qui ont été
choisis comme départements haute quatre
jours de compétition avec comme point de
départ et d'arrivée la vie de mantes la
jolie
le parcours a été dévoilé jeudi les
détails du tracé avec nicolas landry et
mélanie poquet la collégiale notre dame
en témoin de la course
en juin prochain les polos ton feront
une boucle autour de mantes-la-jolie un
circuit dans le vexin en soit le
parcours il n'est pas d'une difficulté
extraordinaire par contre on change
énormément de rythme et c'est ça je
trouve qu'ils donnent à ce côté
technique à ce circuit des boucles de 21
km 104 km pour les femmes 253 pour les
hommes et plusieurs traversées de la
scène un circuit qui devrait sourire aux
sprinteurs je pense qu'il manque une
réelle difficulté pour faire vraiment la
différence est que
malheureusement avec
vu qu'il ya pas de quotas dans les
équipes et qu'on se retrouve parfois
avec des équipes comme la française des
jeux où ils sont 26 coureurs c'est très
facile de contrôler sur un circuit comme
celui là et pour réchapper un sprint il
va falloir
une course de mouvement j'aurais sans
doute aimé un peu plus dur mais bon
je pense qu'il ya ya ya ya ce qu'il faut
quand même après c'est les coureurs qui
font la course
c'est vrai que ces dernières années il
ya eu plus dur mais il ya aussi eu moins
dur donc voilà je pense qu'on peut comme
comme comme souvent on peut avoir un
grand sprinteur qui peut passer et ou
alors au préfet pour les puncheurs les
championnats de france reviennent en
ile-de-france vingt ans après montlhéry
en 97
une nouvelle compétition cycliste pour
le département c'est un très beau sport
c'est un sport praticable par tout le
monde et à tout âge
et puis c'est un sport qui est un sport
de plein air symbolique de ce
département 8 maillot bleu blanc rouge
seront attribués du 28 juin au 1er
juillet verdict dans deux mois faire la
fête à macron c'est l'objectif de la
marche lancé par le député de la france
france un sou mise françois ruffin
marche prévue le samedi 5 mai prochain à
paris les militants de saint quentin en
yvelines sont mobilisés localement ils
ont lancé jeudi soir devant la gare
justement de saint quentin en yvelines
un comité local les initiatives visent à
rassembler les associations syndicats et
étudiants qui partage les causes
défendues par la france insoumise
écouter ces quelques réactions
recueillies par nicolas landry
en fait c'est une manifestation contre
la politique que mène emmanuel macron
compte certains points de sa politique
ou compte de sa politique dans sa
globalité et ce soir comme vous pouvez
le voir ben ya plein de gens qui sont là
pour créer un comité à saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est d'amplifier la pression oui sur le
gouvernement sur toutes les contre
réformes qui sont en train de développer
deux
montrer le mécontentement en fait de
rappeler qu'il n'a pas été élu par plus
de 50% des français mais par 16% du
corps électoral
orange dans le sens des départs et des
retours en ile de france le trafic sera
chargé sur la région ce week end
week-end de vacances bison futé prévoit
notamment des difficultés samedi au
niveau du péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines dans les deux
sens il est conseillé de partir avant 10
heures le matin ou dans la soirée pour
subir le moins de ralentissement
possible
il ne vous reste qu'une dizaine de jours
pour participer aux états généraux de la
bioéthique les débats lancés mi janvier
se termine le 30 avril 30 avril ils
déboucheront à l'automne prochain et
dans quelques mois sur une révision de
la loi de bioéthique de 2011 et sont
l'occasion d'évoquer des sujets éthiques
et moraux très importants qui concernent
l'ensemble des citoyens la fin de vie la
procréation la place de l'intelligence
artificielle dans la médecine notamment
des sujets essentiels donc alors que les
avancées technologiques et médical
dépassent parfois l'entendement humain
des sujets qui peuvent aussi fâché ou
dit viser une société joseph minet
bonsoir vous êtes docteur en bioéthique
vous êtes aussi le président d'une
section locale des associations
familiales catholiques ont dit aussi à
être c'est président de la section de la
celle-saint-cloud précisément je le
disais les états généraux ont débuté en
janvier ils vont se terminer dans leur
partie débat en tout cas dans quelques
jours est-ce que tu point de vue de
votre association vous êtes satisfait de
ce qui a été fait de cette mise en place
pour permettre le débat dans la société
que ce soit localement régionalement ou
même en france
je crois que c'est très important c'est
très important parce que c'est sujet
fâche beaucoup et que la société puisse
s'exprimer dessus c'est essentiel
certains certains regrettent que les
citoyens ne s'approprie pas c'est les
débats que parfois ce sont justement les
associations comme comme les vôtres ou
alors ou alors des partis politiques un
peu conservateur qui sont très actives
sur le sujet est ce que est ce que vous
partagez ce point de vue est ce que vous
regrettez que que les citoyens n'est pas
plus pris la parole dans ce débat
oui non c'est vrai si on va sur le site
des états généraux de la bioéthique
on
tiac seulement quelques milliers de
personnes qui souhaitent exprimer et
c'est vraiment triste parce que je pense
que s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont des
opinions sur ce sujet qui devrait
s'informer s'éduquer mais aussi
s'exprimer
les afc on était elle même très très
actif sur le sur le sujet bien sûr moi
nous avons sur notre site arrive c'est
très l'union france.org
beaucoup d'informations nous avons
réalisé beaucoup de réunions nous avons
fait beaucoup d'activités et nous
cherchons tous les familles membres qui
font partie arrive c'est d'avoir tous
ces informations mais c'est vrai que
c'est difficile en fait de mobiliser les
jambes
ouais il ya beaucoup de sujets pourtant
qui sont très importants et vous le
disais qu'ils vont sûrement faire débat
au moment des discussions on va dire
politique à l'assemblée nationale ou au
sénat parmi ces sujets il y en a
peut-être un qui fait plus que réagir
peut-être aussi parce que on connaît
déjà la position du président de la
république sur le sujet quand il était
candidat il s'était dit favorable à
l'élargissement de la pm à la
procréation médicalement assistée à
toutes les femmes donc même les femmes
gay est ce que est ce que alors
j'imagine votre position à vous vous
êtes je suppose contre pour moi
en fait c'est c'est une énorme évolution
il ya peut-être 10% des couples en
france qui souffrent d'infertilité qui
en est une difficulté d'avoir des
enfants mais la loi en ce moment prévoit
d'aider les gens qui souffrent d'une
infertilité médicale il est en train de
dire qu'en fait il faut aider les gens
qui ont une infertilité sociale c'est à
dire ils veulent un enfant sans passer
par le père généralement et c'est
vraiment problématique parce que j'ai lu
il est à l'étude par exemple un qui
s'appelle my name is done mon papa
s'appelle donateurs et des souffrances
de ces enfants qui vont jamais connaître
leur père et ont fait ça d'une manière
délibérée
alors avant le lancement des états
généraux des sondages on était quand
même réalisé pour prendre le pouls de la
société française et on voit que sur ces
sujets là justement les français
évoluent 60% des interrogés se sont dits
favorables à la
l'ouverture de la pma à toutes les
femmes est ce qu est ce qu il faut en
prendre compte quand on évoque de tels
sujets aussi est ce que c'est important
c'est sûrement intéressant de savoir ce
que pensent les gens je pense ou s'il
serait intéressant de savoir ce que
pensent les gens vraiment c'est dire
s'ils ont vraiment étudié la question ou
si c'est quelque chose qui est un peu
passée dans l'air et je crois que
finalement quand on explique bien la
problématique il ya beaucoup moins de
personnes qui sont favorables alors
parmi les parmi parmi les favorables
enfin les gens qui sont favorables à cet
élargissement de la paix mais il ya un
argument qui peut qu'il peut s'entendre
c'est le fait que la france finalement
n'est pas seul dans ce monde et que dans
d'autres pays on peut on peut faire une
procréation médicalement assistée et que
du coup il faudrait peut-être élargir
pour mieux réglementer pour mieux
encadrer et éviter les dérives parfois
dans certains pays pour que les gens qui
souhaitent le faire reste en france de
façon encadrée avec plus de sécurité ce
que c'est un argument valable est
suffisant selon vous non je pense que le
grand problème quand on légalise quelque
chose dans un pays que tous les autres
pays doivent suivre ça ne va pas de soi
je crois que chaque question en
elle-même doit être étudiée et je pense
ceci parce que la serre aux touches
justement sur la gpa donc la gestation
pour autrui qui se fait généralement à
l'étranger c'est en france allait
totalement interdite jusqu'à présent
mais il ya des personnes qui pensent que
il veut le faire évoluer la même chose
cet argument là est beaucoup utilisé ce
que si c'est légal dans d'autres pays
pourquoi pas chez nous je pense que
c'est important des vers et les choses
sur leurs mérites pas sur la géographie
juste moins pour évoquer la gpa
gestation pour autrui
là pour le coup là aussi c'est assez
clair visiblement même si encore une
fois les débats ne sont pas clos mais on
voit des choses se dessiner dans les
médias aussi lors de la campagne
présidentielle emmanuel macron ne semble
pas favorable à une ouverture de la gp
en france est ce que c'est de nature
quand même à vous rassurer au moins un
petit peu oui je pense
l'idée des mères porteuses est en fait
très offensant pour beaucoup de
personnes de beaucoup de sensibilité et
on voit dans les milieux féministes par
exemple
beaucoup d'activistes qui sont très
content aussi donc il ya je dirais
peut-être plus de consensus sur ce sujet
là pour revenir sur la pma est ce que
vous seriez les avc sont favorables à un
retour en arrière peut-être sur ce sujet
là est ce que vous seriez même au
porteur d'une volonté de retour en
arrière je veux dire et surtout notre
proposition c'est 2 au lieu de pousser
je dirais la fécondation in vitro et
c'est que d'autres technologies qui sont
plus à la pointe est beaucoup moins
invasive etc devraient être mises en
valeur
nous voyons qu'il ya une chose qu'on
appelle à la protection logis c'est à
dire toute une technologie pour aider
les couples qui souffrent d'infertilité
à soigner les problèmes plutôt que de
fabriquer les enfants laboratoire on
trouve que c'est ça qui est plutôt une
voix meilleur qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui disent que c'est une
forme d'inégalité aujourd'hui
d'interdire par exemple aux couples de
femmes d'avoir des enfants grâce à la
pma et que c'est aussi un droit acquis
aujourd'hui de disposer de son corps
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
arguments là on dit surtout qu'il n'ya
pas de droit à l'enfant et la vision
catholique mais je dirais même la vision
humaniste c'est que la personne humaine
ne peut pas s'acheter
on n'a pas le droit de commander un
enfant sur mesure et en fait c'est un
problème de la pma que les gens en
général disent voilà je veux un enfant à
tout prix et je vais me le fabriquer et
même il ya des idées qu'on peut
manipuler en brillant fabriquer beaucoup
de ça c'est un an plus loin c'est encore
plus loin mais c'est dans la même
logique
une fois qu'on a ce droit à l'enfant on
a beaucoup de choses qu'on peut faire
l'idée derrière vos arguments c'est de
dire que finalement il ya des limites
naturelles et qu'il faut les accepter et
les respecter
absolument ouais je dis que quand on va
contre la nature quand on essaye de
manipuler la nature il ya toujours des
conséquences
un mot enfin sur un sur l'un des débats
aussi qui fait beaucoup parler c'est
normal c'est la fin de vie la loi de
2016 la dernière loi autorise une
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'à la
mort pour des cas très encadré les
malades les plus graves
récemment ait eu un avis du conseil
économique social et environnemental qui
a adopté un avis recommandant justement
d'instaurer pour les personnes atteintes
d'une maladie incurable
un droit à bénéficier d'une sédation
profonde explicitement l'êta qui va un
peu plus loin que cette fois de 2016
là aussi visiblement les choses
pourraient bouger quelle est la position
des afc sur la fin de vie
nous pensons que la dignité de la
personne humaine la fin de vie est très
importante et que une pente glissante
on va dans la direction de tuer les
personnes pour qui on tue les personnes
parce qu'il associe on pense aussi en
coupe
la nutrition l'hydratation et ces gens
vont donc mourir de faim et de soif
oui c'est une manière passive mais quand
même de les tuer
ce qui est ce qui est totalement
acceptable c'est tous les soins
palliatifs et c'est pour pallier tous
les souffrances mais pas pour les tuer
activement ou passivement
je voulais avant une réflexion avec vous
pour pour terminer cet entretien / sur
un sentiment depuis depuis quelques
années notamment depuis depuis les
manifestations contre le mariage pour
tous on a l'impression qu'on a une forme
de retour en arrière sur certains sujets
qui n'étaient pas qu'ils n'existaient
pas il ya une dizaine d'années sur
l'avortement c'est des sujets maintenant
qu'on évoque ya beaucoup de gens qui
remettent en cause l'avortement
j'ai eu des candidats aussi à l'élection
présidentielle qui qui semblait ne pas
être forcément favorable au droit à
l'avortement est ce que vous partagez ce
retour au conservatisme en france ou pas
mais je dirais que en france il ya il ya
beaucoup de jeunes personnes qui ont
évolué qui pense à ces questions et qui
finalement trouve que l'avortement ce
n'est pas la manière la plus caritative
bonne de gérer les situations des
conseils ce difficile et que en fait il
faudrait mettre beaucoup plus d'un phase
sur tout ce qui est des deux merveilleux
enfants dans tout les situations
difficiles que finalement ce petit être
on voit l'embryon de plus en plus par la
science est un être vivant qui a le
droit à la vie y a pas de retour en
arrière pour vous des droits des femmes
par exemple quand on évoque le sujet de
l'avortement
je dirais que tout le monde a le droit à
la vie et que finalement le petit enfant
était être alors je le disais les états
généraux c'est jusqu'au 30 avril on va
donner le site internet pour y
participer éventuellement qui va
s'afficher en bas de vos écrans voilà
qui s'affiche à l'instance et jusqu'au
30 avril
un dernier mot quand même puisque vous
êtes en plateau sur le discours d'
emmanuel macron devant les évêques de
france récemment il ya une phrase qui a
marqué
les politiques l'actualité que les
médias ont beaucoup ressorti c'est le
lien je cite un manuel macron dans le
texte
le lien entre l'église et l'état s'est
abîmé et ils vous importe à vous comme à
moi de le réparer est-ce qu'il a raison
de dire ça selon vous certains ont dit
que c'était une atteinte au principe de
laïcité établi en 1905
j'ai trouvé que le geste du président
macron de venir vers les catholiques
étaient très beau très louable en fait
qu'il ya plus de dialogue qui a plus de
lien entre l'état et l'église je dirais
sur le côté institutionnel mais le côté
de dialogue est très important est le
fait qu'ils étaient positifs et qu'ils
voulaient un échange d'idées
c'était très louable et j'espère que ça
va continuer merci joseph minet d'être
venu en plateau d'avoir répondu à toutes
ses questions
vous êtes docteur en bioéthique je le
rappelle est président de l'afc pour la
section locale de la celle-saint-cloud
merci à vous et bon week-end
on passe à l'actualité de la semaine
une première étape pour la rénovation
urbaine des quartiers prioritaires de
trappes la verrière et plaisir il y a
quelques jours le directeur général de
l'anru s'est déplacé dans les yvelines
l' agence nationale pour la rénovation
urbaine a signé un protocole de préfet
préfiguration pour le lancement d'une
phase de conception des projets qui
visent à redéfinir concrètement ces
quartiers et qui ravit aussi les maires
concernés et saint-quentin-en-yvelines
marylène iapichino marion ptac et
patrick jacques de dixmude une signature
enfin acté les communes de trappes la
verrière et plaisir ont inscrits
certains de leurs quartiers dans le
nouveau programme national de
renouvellement urbain dans
l'agglomération ce sont vingt-cinq mille
habitants qui vont pouvoir bénéficier de
nouveaux aménagements sa marque je
dirais le départ de ce nouveau
renouvelle face au nouveau programme de
renouvellement urbain qui fait partie
des grands projets de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de façon à
rééquilibrer son territoire en matière
d'offre de logement une première phase
de conception des projets qui permettra
à l' agence nationale pour la rénovation
urbaine d'établir les budgets accordés à
chaque commune l' agence qui dispose
d'une enveloppe passer de cinq à dix
milliards d'euros récemment à répartir
sur 200 quartier au niveau national par
intérêt de cette phase de préfiguration
de dire et on va porter le niveau
d'ambition à ce niveau-là et de discuter
si on est capable de l'accompagner
jusqu'où et c'est sur cette base là que
se font les enveloppes reconstruction de
logements sociaux à trappes nouvelle
entrée de ville à la verrière
désenclavement du quartier du val hibou
à plaisir autant de projets d'envergure
pour les communes et qui nécessiteront
un travail de concertation avec les
habitants pourront on démarre le le
projet l'estimation de ses financements
sur une idée politico technique je vais
dire ça pour et mais après il ya le
travail et que les habitants c'est avec
les habitants qu'on veut faire le projet
c'est avec eux qu'on veut améliorer la
situation sur place
on est vraiment je dirais heureux d'être
ici tous ensemble ça veut dire que
véritablement il ya un intérêt par
rapport à ces trois villes puisque trois
villes qui sont impactés maintenant on
attend la suite et on attend des choses
concrètes
un processus qui s'inscrit dans un temps
long si de premières améliorations
devraient être visibles dès 2019
les rénovations devraient s'étendre au
moins jusqu'en 2024
à saint quentin en yvelines également
associations et habitat s'inquiète pour
l'avenir de la ferme de bulles loyer
située à magny-les-hameaux depuis plus
d'un an la ferme est inoccupée suite au
départ des jardins de cocagne pour
dénoncer un avenir incertain le
collectif ce qui pousse à organiser un
pique nique il y a quelques jours sur
place avec pour objectif aussi de
sensibiliser sur ce sujet camille
lambert mario ptac et patrick jacques de
dixmude sur ses quatre hectares de
terres poussait une soixantaine de
variétés de légumes de saison en
agriculture biologique
créée en 2010 les jardins de cocagne ont
été obligés de quitter les lieux pour
raisons financières
2016 depuis la ferme de bulles loyer est
inoccupée samedi 14 avril le collectif
ce qui pousse qui réunit associations et
habitants s'est retrouvé pour un pique
nique d'informations et dé change
puisqu'il nous préoccupait fortement
c'était en craignent fortement que sept
fermes disparaissent dans les mains d'un
promoteur ils soient démantelées en
petits lots comme ça arrive souvent
donc ça c'est des rumeurs qui
commençaient à monter du coup on voulait
en savoir plus ce qu'on souhaite c'est
qu'à travers le pique nique
on souhaitait interpeller déjà les
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
et en même temps nos élus sur le devenir
de cette belle ferme de abu loyers en
octobre 2017 l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines propriétaire de la
ferme a signé une convention avec la
safer pour trouver un nouveau projet sur
ce lieu le collectif regrette le manque
de communication et souhaite conserver
le côté local comme c'était le cas avec
les jardins de cocagne
on n'a aucune information sur ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qui est c'est quoi le
contenu de cette combat sur convention
et c'est quoi le valais projet pour ce
concept ferme et on s'inquiète beaucoup
en fait on veut pas que cette ferme
perdre sa vocation agricole tout
simplement parce qu on y est attaché
l'intérêt de rapprocher l'agriculture
des citoyens surtout en ile de france on
est quand même assez éloignée des tags
et culture je pense que c'est un terrain
propice à des expérimentations enfin si
saint-quentin veut vraiment être dans le
mouvement on va dire dans le mouvement
actuel on voit bien que s'il ya un
engouement réel
contacté par nos soins l'agglomération a
indiqué que l'appel à projets a été
lancé et suit son cours même si l'avenir
de la ferme reste incertain il devrait
rester agricole mercredi la secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes marlène schiappa
était en déplacement à plaisir elle
s'est rendue à la maison des familles
flora tristan sur place à la pu
rencontrer les membres de 1001 mots
cette association aide les parents dans
l'éveil du langage de leurs enfants
avant l'entrée en maternelle une action
pour réduire les inégalités dès le plus
jeune âge marlène schiappa est
d'ailleurs devenue la marraine de cette
structure plaisir oise propos recueillis
par patrick jacques de dixmude à dans
une ludothèque
unité de lieu et bien il ya des parents
qui partage autour des jeux qui font
découvrir à leurs bébés la découverte de
l'objet du livre
et puis la découverte des mots et les
changes de quelques pratiques entre les
parents pour avoir véritablement une
interaction une communication efficace
avec leurs enfants pour qu'à terme cette
acquisition du langage elle soit plus
facile pour les enfants et aussi pour
les parents pour nous c'est important
parce que aujourd'hui notre association
elle travaille sur un certain nombre de
terrains plutôt en ile de france dans
les yvelines à paris dans le val de
marne
mais on veut montrer aussi que elle a
une ambition nationale puisque le modèle
qu'on a développée donc des groupes de
parents avec une maman ambassadrice ce
modèle il peut être étendue à beaucoup
d'autres territoires et on est persuadé
que un peu partout en france
il ya des mamans ambassadrice potentiel
qu'on pourrait trouver mercredi
également pascal thévenot le maire les
républicains de vélizy était l'invité du
7-8 le journal il est revenu sur la
campagne pour la présidence de la
fédération locale des républicains si
mais si les militants seront appelés à
voter en octobre la campagne elle a bien
débuté avec notamment la candidature du
président du département pierre bédier
et celle d'alexandra dublanche
conseiller régional élu à sartrouville
c'est elle que pascal thévenot soutien
pour l'élection un soutien et qui le
justifie par une volonté de renouveau
écoutez c'est lent gmail envie de
rassembler toutes les idées tous ceux
qui veulent apporter on est d'accord sur
l'essentiel on a des vues des fois
différente à la marge et je pense que
c'est avant tout de remobiliser et de
redonner confiance à l'électeur de
droite et du centre qui a pris un gros
coup sur la tête et ça sera ma dernière
question comment justement remobiliser
d'ici cette élection laissait de
multiplier peut-être les rendez-vous de
terrain les réunions
dans les rangs du terrain les débats les
discuter de certains sujets comme
d'actualité qui peuvent être aujourd'hui
immigration et les collectivités
territoriales eux l'économie la dette et
pour que on a désigné on s'est toujours
intéressé aux faits politique au sens
noble et on a un grand vivier
il faut pas les décevoir et aujourd'hui
ils ont tous envie d'avoir un baron
c'est peut-être un peu fort mais une
personne qui vous explique que demain il
faut que les affiches et par contre les
idées il a besoin de débattre les
connaît en bref mardi les étudiants de
l'ub est est ce qu ont voté contre le
blocage de l'établissement la décision a
été prise en assemblée générale alors
que vous le savez un mouvement de
protestation contre la réforme de
l'accès à l'université secoue en ce
moment le monde universitaire avec des
blocages notamment à sciences po paris
et nanterre où les examens ont été
reportés la france lui a rendu un
hommage national saint cyr l'école va
baptiser l'un de ces boulevards au nom
d'arnaud beltrame ce boulevard colonel
arnaud belle trame se situera dans la
zac renard en cours d'achèvement
les élus l'ont décidé à l'unanimité lors
du dernier conseil municipal un geste
pour honorer est la mémoire du gendarme
tué lors de l'attaqué terroriste de très
bons en mars dernier l'officier avait
suivi les cours de classe préparatoire
au lycée militaire de saint cyr avant
d'intégrer l'armée de terre en 1995 un
appel aux dons d'urgence l'établissement
français du sang fait face à une baisse
drastique de ses réserves moins 15% de
donateurs en ile de france depuis le
début de l'année notamment à cause des
intempéries
et ce alors que se profilent les
week-ends prolongés du mois de mai
habituellement mauvais pour la collecte
pour évoquer le sujet stéphane noël le
directeur régional de l'établissement
français était l'invité du journal lundi
nous vivons généralement avec 12 jours
de stocks actuellement nous sommes en
dessous de ça nous avons dix jours de
stock voit un petit peu moins sur
certains groupes
de fait nous sommes sous tension
d'autant que les vacances
ont commencé il y à des pompes qui sont
extrêmement importants une semaine
blanche la semaine de la semaine et
surtout la semaine du 8 mai sont des
semaines qu'ils sont extrêmement
difficiles
et comme vous l'avez compris nous ne
pouvons pas nous permettre d'avoir des
interruptions de collègues pendant ces
périodes là de fait nous devons
absolument connectés en permanence nous
appelons vraiment les donneurs à se
mobiliser
d'autant que nous avons d'autres
conséquences qui aujourd'hui nous
impacte et en particulier les mouvements
sociaux les mouvements sociaux par
exemple en allemagne via à devoir
annuler des collectes en raison de lieu
de manifestation dans paris qui est en
pêche certaines de nos collègues de se
tenir
donc nous appelons vraiment tous les
donneurs aujourd'hui assurent leur
maximum pour venir nous voir et donner
maintenant et pour savoir où donner et
quand consulter le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran
c'est la fin de ce cette fuite l'hebdo
autour de l'actualité en direct lundi à
18h sur l'antenne de tv 78 d'ici là
restez connectés et informés grâce à
notre implication et notre site internet
tv 78 points comme bon week-end à tous
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]